by now we've all heard the news about
the tragedy in our nation this morning
obviously what happened is unspeakable I
don't see how we could possibly go ahead
with our scheduled meeting about this
year's company pullovers but we
absolutely must
okay so let's just dive right in
do we like the polar fleece or the
brushed fleece Felicity if you need to
take a moment that's fine
just turn around in your chair so I
didn't see you listen I know this is
tough but it's time-consuming to fill
this bed and we can't afford that not on
fleece day also anyone who needs grief
counseling today can talk to grace she's
our Rock grace well - we be